okay today we look at another attempt to
brainwash
and indoctrinate our kids through
children's literature
uh this one and we've done several of
these
videos because unfortunately there are
so many of these kinds of books on the
bookshelf if you go to barnes noble
or any other bookstore this one is
called the gay bcs
because of course the regular abcs are
not good enough
if you're a gay activist you need your
own abcs so you got the gay bc's this is
written by
m.l webb and uh i'll just read the book
description of the book it says a play
date extravaganza transforms into a
celebration of friendship
love and identity as four friends sashay
out of all the closets dress up in a
wardrobe fit for kings and queens
and discover the wonder of imagination
that's what the book is now we know
it's an abc book so what's the i think
we should keep this in mind as we
as we go through it what's the age range
of a book like this
you know i'd say probably three years
old to
seven three to sevens about the age
range for a book of this kind
and that's what all the content in this
book is directed towards our kids of
that age
now usually when we do these these
videos i'll read the book ahead of time
a little bit
just to get an idea of what i'm getting
myself into in this case i didn't really
do that so i'm going to be experiencing
this
with you all of us together at once and
let's go uh
let's go through i don't know you know
there are how many letters in the
alphabet
last i checked there was 26 so i don't
know if we can get through all 26 pages
but we'll try
all right the kbc's a is for ally
a friend who is there to stand up for
you with strength love
and care b is for bi
you can shout it out loud i like boys
and girls
and that makes me proud
bisexual is uh
this is again we're talking kids three
to seven years old
and we're talking to them about being
bisexual yeah for all the
all the four-year-old bisexuals out
there
you know what if a four-year-old is
not bisexual he's not gay
kids at that age don't don't have a
sexuality that's something that is
that develops over time and never mind
the fact
that makes why would you even that makes
me proud i like boys and girls and i'm
proud of that
why should there be pride in your sexual
orientation in the first place i never
quite understood that
c is for coming out you're ready to
share what you feel deep inside
it's okay to be scared d is for drag you
can strut and dance
in clothes that you love dresses heels
or pants
now remember drag is burlesque for gay
men
that's what it is i mean that's that's
the history of of drag it's adult
oriented it's highly sexual by its
nature
and that's why when you look at a lot of
these drag queens for the drag queen
story hours
and the names that they have even the
even the stage names that they choose
are clearly sexual in nature and then
you just move your pub up and down like
that
and that's twerking so when drag is
being
foist on kids that's what's being voiced
e is for equality we're on the same team
we all have the right
to love hope and dream that's true i
can't
i can't disagree with that we all do
have the right to love hope and dream
whatever that means i have the right to
dream and hope
you do i'll agree with you there f is
for family related or found
they'll stick by your side through your
ups and downs
g is for gay it's a word that implies
you're a girl who likes girls
or a guy who likes guys h is for hope
dream up a life that you'll love the sky
is the limit
shoot for the stars above and now we're
really getting into it here with i
i is for intersex some are born with the
parts of both a boy and a girl
bodies are works of art uh okay yeah
some are born intersex and by some we
mean about seven people in the whole
world
but for some reason they get lumped into
this conversation why are
let me let me ask you why are intersex
people
so-called why are they lumped in with
with gay
trans what do they have to do with
anything intersex that's a
that's a a medical condition that's a
deformity
that's what that is so why are we
lumping people who suffer from a
deformity in with what do they have to
do with anything
intersex people are always brought in
especially when the topic is trans
and uh and the left they're trying to
justify their position on gender they
say what about intersex people
what about them what do they have to do
with anything
just because they're intersex people how
does that validate or legitimize
a biological man who claims to be a
woman
how does the existence of a of a birth
defect that he doesn't have
validate what he's claiming
and then why are we telling kids about
intersex at what point in a
four-year-old's life do you say to
yourself
you know what i got to sit little johnny
down and tell him about uh
and give him the intersex talk why does
it why does a four-year-old need to know
about inner
there are 12 intersex people in the in
the world why does a four-year-old need
to know about them
and also born born with a boy with the
parts of a boy and a girl it's more
accurate to say that an intersex person
is born with with parts that can look
ambiguous to us or that are un it's
it can be it could be unclear from a
physical examination
what biological sex this individual is
it doesn't mean that they
don't have a biological sex and it
certainly doesn't mean that they are
both biological sexes
okay because really being born with the
parts of a boy and a girl what that
would actually mean
if we're talking literally here is that
you would have
a person who has the functional
reproductive capacity
of both a male and a female and that
type of person
has never existed in the human species
ever that type of person does not exist
there has never been a person
who has the ability to impregnate
and be pregnant because that's what it
would really mean to have the parts of a
boy and a girl
that's never existed ever what has
existed are birth defects okay
j is for joy you can sing dance and play
find moments of sunshine in each and
every day
k is for kiki k is for kiki
what k i ki kiki when friends come
together to catch up on news
gossip and weather is that some sort of
gay
thing what is that i'm gonna look it up
i'm gonna google this
very quickly just because i need to know
for my own
i don't know what's about to pop up on
my computer right now when i google
kiki but i'm doing this on camera so
that you know it's it's known
whatever whatever ends up in my search
engine here it's only because
this is for my own edification go to
wikipedia
kiki alternatively kiking is a term
which grew out of black american gay
social culture
and is loosely defined as a gathering of
friends for the purpose of
gossiping and chitchat and later made
more widely known in the song
let's have a kiki by the scissor sisters
a kiki is a party for calming all your
nerves
dear god
let's reference a song by the scissor
sisters
for the four-year-olds who are this who
are reading this book
l is for lesbian it's love and affection
between two special girls who share a
connection
m is for mountain the peaks that you'll
move with courage and strength found
deep inside
you is mountain is that a gay term too i
don't even know anymore
are we talking about actual mountains or
is there some sort of gay subculture
thing going on that i don't know about
n is for non-binary you don't identify
as just being a girl or just being a guy
which of course means
nothing whatsoever because
as i always say young kids
a young boy doesn't know what a girl is
really
doesn't even really know what a boy is
he has very little understanding of any
of this
and so for a young boy to say i don't
identify as a boy
that is a statement that has no meaning
coming out of his mouth
and actually it has no meaning coming
out of the mouth of anybody even an
adult
o is for orientation it's a balance
between
who you are who you love and how you
want to be seen
p is for pam you connect with a vibe no
matter the gender
it's about what's inside that sounds
very scientific connecting with a vibe
what does that mean exactly
and yeah that's a that's another con
pansexual so pansexual from what i
understand
is someone who is attracted to anything
all takers um and that's a concept that
we need to
introduce to kids of course q is for
queer in an inclusive term it's used to
show pride
unite and affirm your queer is
interesting because
it was a slur and then but then we were
told no actually
it's it's because this is what they do
with language they
a word is okay and then the left says no
it's a slur now
and then a few years later they say oh
actually no you're allowed to say that
now in this con
certain people are allowed to use it in
this context
and we're supposed to just follow follow
along obediently
r is for respect it's the right decision
to treat everyone fairly
make it your mission you know it's not
the right decision to write a book like
this
for kids you freak
can we can we clarify one thing um
what is this book responding to
right what is what is what it is what is
it the answer to because
you can't say that oh we needed um a gay
alphabet book
uh you know in order to be inclusive
because of all those
straight heterosexual alphabet books out
there and we need all this gay stuff for
kids because of all the
of all the straight heterosexual
children stories
no there was never any there wasn't any
straight heterosexual alphabet book for
kids there was just an alphabet book
and it was things like a is for apple
b is for bicycle
i'm not aware of any book that was
pushing
any children's book whether alphabet or
otherwise that was pushing
heterosexuality on kids
it was more like before we started doing
stuff like this the idea was
we don't need to introduce those
concepts to kids at all because they're
kids and it's not relevant to them right
now and it's not appropriate for them
s is for sachet a confident fierce
stride
to show yourself off with attitude and
pride
t is for trans it's a brave step to take
to live as the
gender you know is innate uh
well it's not an eight though because
innate something is innate if it be
if it belongs something is innate to you
if it belongs to your
essential nature you know if it's
fundamental to you
and if you're a biological male then
being a female
is the opposite of an eight it doesn't
belong to your nature whatsoever
u is for unique there's no one like you
embrace who you are
and love what you do v is for vogue time
to strike a pose
dance to the music and put on a show w's
for wonder with so much to know
always ask questions to think learn and
grow x is for
x x is for x
uh you can write it down when you don't
prefer m or f
as your pronoun um
y is for you brave creative and strong
you are special and loved and you'll
always belong
z is for zest be bold and live free
magic awaits you whoever you'll be all
right i can't believe i actually got
through this whole damn
disgusting film i i have normally been
opposed to book
burning but i would make an exception um
for that appalling mass of insanity and
filth
you know we always hear people
complaining about things being offensive
and most of the time the offensive thing
is not really offensive at all
or shouldn't be but this that that right
there that is
offensive that is actually offensive i
admit i am
yeah call me a snowflake i am personally
offended by that i am offended by the
sexual indoctrination of children
i am upset by predators like the author
of that
book grooming children that does offend
me
it does because that's what this is this
is grooming
imagine if you were out with your child
uh
on the playground and a grown-ass man
walked up to your kid and said hey
little boy
uh want me to tell you what a pansexual
is
hey kid come here are you bi are you
bisexual you wanna hear about bisexuals
let me tell you about it come to my van
and i'll tell you about it
if a man started talking to your kid
that way you would react
in a way that communicates your feelings
about that right and what i mean is you
would punch him in his throat
and for good reason i see no difference
between that
situation on a playground and a book
like like this
made for kids objectionable creepy
insane disgusting in summary i didn't
like it
i award this negative 12 stars out of 5.